foreign
[Music]
century
oh sorry I forgot the words
so everyone give it up for Kevin forever
uh you got here early you were not meant
to see that despite matabita Heidi that
was
incredible sorry should I say Karen
frerein
was barely adequate I am not ready to
play it for anyone yet I perform under
Karen fraring so that I can get honest
feedback on my songwriting but
it is My Little Secret so I
oh that is hilarious all I've ever
wanted was to be famous on stage
performing for millions of people as
they chant my legal name Tim Allen Tim
Allen yeah well you never get a second
chance to make a first impression and if
I am not perfect when I step out as
Heidi I will just be another American
Army brat who stayed in Germany to go to
Music School who never made it Tale As
Old As Time and this is just one guy's
opinion but I thought Karen Farren it's
one of the best singers I've ever heard
and I've seen Pentatonix live
before they kicked me out for trying to
climb on the stage I
well thank you but in your text you seem
pretty upset what's going on
there's nothing
just
Peter lied to me and I found out that
I'm not famous outside of one stupid
Tick Tock and yeah I uh
I started to get the sense that you
didn't know the whole story but I know
Peter I kept working for him after the
DSM Scandal because
his heart is in the right place he just
got my hopes up
I thought Berlin was going to change
everything
could
go tomorrow
seven million people watched your video
a million people that's what I said
I wouldn't two days ago bumper kill for
the chance to sing on stage in front of
an audience
[Music]
if I do this I have to start from
scratch if you're starting from scratch
might as well start in a place where you
have a new friend
me
[Music]
[Music]